so
the title i'd like to at least give you
to give the title before i uh hand it
over so it's
virtuous and vicious anger what
aristotle has
to uh to teach us uh
thanks so um you might ask well why
why aristotle you know is just this guy
has a thing for for aristotle so he
found some way to work it in
you know those of you who are in the
ethics class you are
doing some virtue ethics in aristotle
but the connection to say environmental
ethics is not one that's immediately
obvious um i'm interested in aristotle
on anger
in part because if you look at the
history of philosophy and that would
include
you know philosophy sort of writ large
so it includes some theological thinkers
and people we now associate with
psychology
you look at the way that they treat
anger
there are a few consistent trends that
you can see
most philosophers see anger is a
uniformly bad thing so cicero will say
for example
anger never good john cassian a
christian monastic writer who wrote
about the desert fathers
the only time it's good to be angry is
when you're angry at yourself and
only angry at your your own vices um
plato's a little bit you know all over
the map when it comes to it because he
didn't have a theory of anger
um but he tends to see it as a dangerous
thing
he tends to see the emotions is fairly
dangerous the stoics
definitely anger's a bad thing the
epicureans bad thing
most of the the christian writers until
we get to people like aquinas
it's almost uniformly bad in modern
philosophy
the tendency tends to be to turn anger
just into one more emotions like like
the others
and um treat it accordingly but
sometimes you find people who still say
it's uniformly bad like jeremy bentham
for example somebody who you might
encounter when you're doing
authoritarianism
more likely you're reading mill though
right
okay well there you go bentham thought
that anger is always a sign of what he
calls the the motive of
malevolence that's always bad
aristotle thinks and here he's rather
unusual
that anger can be a good thing
and we also live in a society that's
rather schizophrenic when it comes to
anger you know we see glorifications
of angry behavior in in media but we're
told
quite often and you'll be told a lot
more as you
you know proceed through all the sorts
of landmarks of adult life that anger is
just you know it's not the right
thing to do so aristotle's an
interesting guy to look at because he
provides us with
some sort of way of seeing anger in some
cases and i want to really stress that
in some cases
as a positive thing so he also gives us
a really sophisticated understanding
about how anger works
and that's something that's important
for figuring out whether it can be a
good thing
he gives us an analysis of anger as
an emotional response in terms of habits
in terms of
action in terms of attitudes and one of
the handouts that i've given you i've
given you a lot of handouts and i don't
expect you to like you know peruse them
all
right now they're for for reference but
one of them is
about aristotelian texts that actually
treat dimensions of anger
and you notice that there are a lot of
different
spots in aristotle where he's examining
the emotion
or you know the morality or
the responsibility our reasoning
processes
dealing with anger and as i've been
doing the research for
the book i've distinguished between
a lot of different dimensions of anger
that aristotle discusses
and i'm not going to go through all six
of them here but let me just distinguish
three of them
we can look at anger as what we call a
somatic response soma is the body
what happens when you get angry what
happens to you i know like my ears turn
red because i've had students tell me
that
i had students who actually i used to
teach in a maximum security prison
and i would have students who would
deliberately try to get me angry in
class because they like to see me get
angry
weird that they'd want to do that but
you know what happens to you when you
get angry
physically yeah
oh that's bad yeah that's really bad for
your jaw and teeth but
common response yeah
yeah that that's more on the level of
the emotions
um but if you know there's some physical
basis for that we're thinking yeah um
somebody else had their hand up
yeah you know aristotle actually he was
working with natural science in a time
when they
hadn't developed it very well because
anger a boiling of the blood near the
heart if we want to talk about it
physically
yeah like heart rate increases
yeah yeah i don't get angry very
like often adrenaline rush i get that
too i would actually
get the shakes from all the adrenaline
flowing through my system
um
ah that that happens too do you get like
does your body get rigid too
hence any of you yeah
yeah that's why anger can sometimes give
you headaches because your neck gets all
intense
flushing yeah so these are all somatic
responses
and you know you could go further with
this you could do mris of angry people
those are a little bit limited in how
much they can actually tell us because
you got to put somebody in the machine
and try to provoke them it's a little
bit artificial right
but it tells us something and aristotle
thinks that that matters
but that matters less than what we might
call the phenomenological
way in which we experience anger what is
it like to actually
get angry the tunnel vision is kind of
part of that the irrationality
the like focusing in on you know a few
things and not letting them go
that's characteristic of anger if you
read anger management textbooks they'll
tell you the first thing you need to
know about anger
is once you get angry you become dumb
becomes stupid no matter how intelligent
you are
because that's part of the dynamic of
the emotion
of anger and aristotle is going to tell
us about what anger actually
consists in emotion he's pretty good
when it comes to that
then we can look at anger on a yet
higher level
in terms of ethics is it right or wrong
to get angry are we responsible for our
anger
those are ethical questions those are
not questions that you can answer just
by looking at the body
or just by looking at how the emotions
work you have to look at
choices people make habits the criteria
that they use so that's all
you know sort of background information
to get us get us
sort of prepped for this let's talk now
about virtue ethics so you had a brief
introduction
to it before and i have a handout again
handouts for
each you know part of what we're going
to do today the handout for you on the
app
i also have an exercise that i'm not
going to have you do in class today but
it's the one about character traits
and i'd like you to complete it and
bring it to
uh dr festmeyer's class as sort of
homework
uh and i'll i'll give him some ideas
about you know how to
parse parsley i'm sure he's got some
good ideas already but you notice that
character traits do matter to us when it
comes to ethics
ethics is not just about rules it's not
just about
duties it's not just about outcomes
as human beings we're interested in what
kind of people are we
and what are the traits of a good person
we could try to get away from that but
it always
there's an old expression about nature
that the ancients had
you can you know throw nature out with a
pitchfork but it will always come back
through
the back door the same thing will happen
with character traits if you if you go
further in reading bet them or go
further in reading [ __ ]
you're going to find that they're going
to have to talk about that sort of thing
and make sense of it mill as well so
virtue ethics um why is it called virtue
ethics well we look at things called
virtues
and vices and we look at those as our
main evaluative criteria um
oftentimes we'll contrast it against
other approaches i'm not sure
if you've done that in in the class if
you like done some compare contrast
like okay so
you know some of the comparisons we
could make would be
would be between sort of
consequentialist a big family of
consequentialist ethics
um most you know represented
by by utilitarianism and current policy
debates and things things like that
but you know egoist consequentialism
would fit in over there
and then we have what often you call
deontological or duty-based
ethics or non-consequentialist ethics
and then you know where does virtue
ethics fit in well it doesn't
it's a third thing it's it's a
distinctive approach
that has some elements of both of those
that can take into account what's good
in those
but but goes beyond them um
there's some other interesting things
that have been going on in ethics
recently
have you guys talked about ethics of
care at all in your class
we mentioned it maybe it was the last
class yeah uh talking briefly about
feminist ethics and a different approach
than the one that we were talking about
when you guys remember we were talking
about singer and reagan and
utilitarianism
and kantian theological thought and so
there was this other view
that says that emotions and actually
caring about something
is morally relevant or morally important
and not to be sung
yeah and so we talked about it last
class period but that was all we said
so that would be another another you
know polarity to ethics
and there's a lot of conjunctions
between a lot of ethics of care people
don't realize the better ones do
but a lot of them don't realize exists
between ethics of care and virtue ethics
because when they're doing their work
very well they're actually doing
something very similar to classic virtue
the emotions matter for aristotle just
as much as they do for virginia health
um or uh carol gilligan pick whoever you
like
michael sloat um so
where where ethics of care probably goes
further is in emphasizing the importance
of relationships
the fact that the self is not you know
an atom
uh the way it's often been represented
but you can also get that out of virtue
ethics as well
um i want to make a distinction here too
between two different ways of seeing
virtue ethics in relation to these other
world things so i've contrasted virtue
ethics to a bunch moral theories
you could say well virtue ethics is is
you know just a separate thing
it's got its own criteria for
utilitarianism what's the criteria does
anyone remember
right offhand because get a little
formula
greatest
yeah that's a good way to put it
greatest happiness principle you know
maximize pleasure minimize pain across
the board
what if you're a conscience
there's a special principle that
memorize
yeah there you go it's got several
formulations they get a little tricky
when you actually go to apply them
and there actually seems to be a little
consequentialism mixed in there but
according to the kant there you know
it's
pure um so that would be there
in london
yeah so you get two different criteria
there right uh
ethics of care what would be the caring
thing what would be the empathetic thing
that might be one of the criteria
virtue ethics what would be what would
be the virtuous thing how would a
virtuous person
now we're treating each of these as
excluding the others
as exclusionary that's not the way
ethics really works
when you guys come out of this class and
you put together
some sort of way of meandering through
your life and threading
the many very tight needles of moral
decision making that you're faced with
you're not going to like whip out you
know some laminated card with a
categorical imperative on it and say
well i'm a conscience so i just
i only go by this no utilitarianism for
me
um there are conscience who take that
into account there are virtue ethics
virtue ethicists
who can say outcomes matter you know
duties matter rules do matter but we
need to
we need to integrate them into a better
way of looking at things into a more
comprehensive system so that's the kind
of virtual ethics that aristotle offers
us
that we're looking at today i do want to
say um
two other things about about virtue
ethics as well well actually three other
things
particularly since there's a
environmental ethics class
um so one one thing that goes wrong with
virtue ethics
people will sometimes think that well
you just provide a list of virtues
and say you know you could make a poster
see this in a lot of workplaces right
courage perseverance maybe you have some
pictures
like a little cat hanging on that's
perseverance right
a cat you know ready to scratch that's
courage
and i don't know what you do for justice
a cat sharing a you know
cat food with another cat perhaps fairly
equitably
they start to break down that's not yet
doing virtue ethics
that's just naming virtues in order to
actually be doing virtue ethics this is
the second thing i want to say
we need to actually be thinking about
what is a virtue
it's not enough just to name them or to
you know create
pictures however compelling they may be
we have to
actually have some account of what
justice is
or what prudence is or what
empathy if that's going to be a virtue
is
we have to do some some thinking about
this the the
third thing i want to say about this and
then we're going to look at
aristotle's virtue ethics um
because most of the
major theorists who were associated with
virtue ethics tend to be ancient
medieval
really modern thinkers it's often seen
as something necessarily conservative
necessarily you know stuck in the past
not not radical not reactionary
reactionary not radical not liberating
any of those sorts of things not engaged
in cultural criticism
if you actually look at plato or you
look at
aristotle you will see them intensely
critical of their own cultures
aristotle says not a single one of the
currently
existing greek regimes and he you know
wrote books on
over 100 of them has good laws
not a single one of them here's how they
could be improved these guys were social
reformers
there are certain respects like we were
talking uh before class aristotle
you know aristotle thought that that
slavery could in fact in certain
circumstances be a good thing
he did in fact get used by southern
slave holders
to provide justifications they really
had to twist the text just as much as
they did with the bible in order to
make that happen but but it did happen
he's got some blind spots
but virtue ethics as an approach
there's nothing to necessarily tie it in
with some sort of conformism
or you know lack of cultural critique
one of the most important virtue
ethicists around today aleister mcintyre
is in fact what we call a revolutionary
aristotelian
he's if you go to the mcintyre
conferences you'll see a mix of
aristotelians and thomas and then you
know people like me who are not
affiliated
and marxists mcintyre was a marxist and
he brought all that forward
so virtue ethics can actually provide us
with a really
solid way of critiquing our current
institutions our current practices
our current culture to say what people
are calling courage today actually isn't
courage here's what real courage would
look like
um or you know justice or or
self-indulgence versus temperance
so it's a really useful um
point i think um
one of the things i wanted you to to
look at in this was i've got this hand
out
it's very long handouts like three pages
afterwards take a look at it it's got
you know aristotle's position on virtue
advice or broken down
into schemas that'll be very helpful for
you i'm going to give you just the
bullet points of it
when aristotle talks about a virtue or
advice as opposed to some other thinkers
who use those terms
he means what we call a habit a subtle
disposition
so for example how many of you
would describe yourself as a generous
person
okay can you be relied upon
in most circumstances not necessarily
all to act generously
no then you're not a generous person
according to aristotle if you can't be
relied upon
it's good to be honest though i mean
when i ask about honesty how many of you
are
then you get to raise your hand for that
one right because you're actually
copying to something
how many of you leave good tips
um what else goes into generosity how
many of you are willing to loan a book
to a friend even though you may not get
even though you probably whenever you
loan books you're probably not going to
get that book back
what else might go into generosity how
many of you would give of your time
even though you've got some sort of
obligation
because you have a friend who can't
change a tire and you can
let's assume you couldn't change a tire
who can't
see these are the sort of things that go
into generosity
and those are actions it's the matrix of
those actions the habit
that is a virtue what might be the
opposite of generosity
being greedy okay
being stingy selfishness okay
what does that look like in a person if
somebody really is selfish they don't
just do a selfish action
you can rely on them to be selfish
whenever presented with the opportunity
so what's a selfish person like at a
party
what are the sort of things they might
do if they wouldn't bring anything
to the party what they would
take everything they'll eat all the food
they'll they'll drink you know
whatever's available
they'll drink the best stuff too you
know um the high-end stuff they'll break
into the cabinet
um what else might they do let's
make a mess not don't worry about
cleaning it up now the kind of person
who does that characteristically
we would say that person has a vice
aristotle would call that a vice
um and he actually we're not going to
talk about that vice here but he talks
about that
in his ethics so these are dispositions
and they're dispositions that have to do
with behavior yeah
um just to go back to virtue and how it
has to be a habit
isn't that gonna be can we say that it's
subjective
because it really would depend on what
people
value and how often they do it and what
might be generosity to you
yeah so they're subjective and then
they're subjective
um there's nothing that you're going to
find in human behavior
that is purely 100
objective in that it has no
participation
of human subjectivity within it but
there's there's
bad subjectivity like it's totally
arbitrary
it's all over the map and then you know
there is a there's good subjectivity as
paul recur calls it
um aristotle thinks that we can't
actually come up with criteria for what
counts as generosity he thinks that some
people are actually wrong
about what counts as generosity and some
people are closer to what's right
one of the interesting things about
virtue ethics is it can explain to us
why that is people who are screwed up
tend to have screwed up moral
perceptions
so if i'm a stingy person aristotle says
if i'm a vicious person in general i
don't realize i'm vicious usually
i think i'm the norm and everybody else
is screwed up
now you know there's there is
some some sort of you know looseness or
play in there
but we can we can approximate to um
characteristics that we can say well in
most cases is what most reasonable
people would call generosity
if if generosity is going to mean
something like i give everything i've
got
all the time uh you know in a
pathological way
where it's totally damaging to me and my
family there are some people who think
that's what generosity is
aristotle would say well they're they're
not standard
um who who is the standard virtuous
people we look to the ones who
actually exhibit those qualities and do
it reliably
for our standard of how to behave now it
doesn't mean we couldn't be wrong about
it aristotle
one of the ones that he
seems to have gotten quite wrong is
what he calls great soulness magnaminity
which is this kind of pride
pride in oneself and later authors came
and said
yeah he that one he he's great about the
justice he's great about the courage
that one
he's really encouraging a kind of bad
behavior um
so you know there's a sort of cultural
growth in this as well
there's other virtues that i think
aristotle could have talked about
but you know if he wasn't our time you
would have like say empathy
doesn't talk about it um
so there you know there's there's we can
sort of approximate along
and get it to a better position
that's a good important question though
so um
going back to aristotle you guys have
talked about the mean
right mean means the middle and it's not
just you know there's a vice over here
and a vice over here and i
try to aim for the middle like i'm going
you know driving a boat through boys or
something
to get to the marina um it's rather
about proportion
so what would be the generous let me go
back to tips again and generosity
what's a generous tip what do you guys
leave what do you feel good about
leaving if you have good service
what percent okay so that's a good
guideline yeah
over 20 if you're in the service
industry it's probably 30 percent
uh because you actually have a much
greater appreciation of what it's like
to get you know
your tips and get shafted on tips and
have good tips and bad tips and
all that sort of thing but 20 is good
i'm from the midwest
and it took me a while to acclimate to
this because
at least where i grew up you know what
good service gets
15 and
okay service 10 you know what bad
service gets
in wisconsin any
penny left on the table in full view to
say
this was not good this is all i'm
leaving for you
um now i had to i had to acclimate uh
my wife was very instrumental in that um
because you know she's
she works at the culinary so she knows a
lot of people in the service industry
and she's a more generous person than i
am and so over time
i look at generous people and i sort of
try to align my
my own behavior with them and i even go
against my own instincts in doing so
that took a lot of doing to get me to
leave more than 15 percent i believe
you know may sound kind of silly but
yeah
well then it wouldn't be generosity
that's that's a that's a um
where we get to like you know the why of
what
what's going on oh absolutely in virtue
ethics the why
matters um for
aristotle it's not just being in the
middle
it's doing the right thing for the right
reason
at the right time with the right people
if if being generous you know means
like just throwing dollar bills around
you know make it rain uh that sort of
thing
um that might be giving money to the
wrong people
real generosity like looks to who you're
actually helping out
real courage doesn't mean like getting
fist fights you know to protect
everybody
maybe some people can stick up for
themselves and you don't need to get
involved in those
yeah then you have fake generosity
then you have fake generosity
it's better than not being generous i
mean here's the thing
it's better than it's better to behave
to fake it till you make it even if you
never make it it's better to do that
for good things than to not do anything
right
but it's it's yet better to actually
have the right motivations to have the
right um
as aristotle says the the person who
actually has virtue takes pleasure
in acting virtuously if i have to
if i want to look generous and i'm i'm
doing it even though
like every time it's killing me inside
i'm dying a little bit
then i'm what he would call the
self-controlled person i'm not the
virtuous person
and that's a good thing that's better
than being uncontrolled better than
being vicious
but it's not yet being virtuous yeah so
if the virtuous
person takes pleasure and acting
virtuously yeah are they not acting
virtuously
only to receive that now aristotle
aristotle talks about that
um if that were the case then he'd just
be a heatedness like epicurus or
aristippus
he says that pleasure is something that
comes to them through doing it they want
to do
what is actually the right action and
they enjoy doing the right action
as as a result it's not if they're only
doing it to try to get pleasure out of
it
it's a dumb way to try to get pleasure
because there's a lot better ways to get
pleasure
you know for other people but well
virtuous person
it could be the best way to get pleasure
the virtuous person
is going to be well integrated so
they're going to have a lot of different
ways they can get pleasure
and some ways are available to everybody
you know um
you want to get drunk you just drink
some some alcohol
anybody can do that and that's enjoyable
until you know later on
drink too much of it
you know aristotle thinks that if if
you're only doing it to
get kicks out of it you're not yet
virtuous
your virtue is when it's become part of
who you are
um you know if you ask people who are
high performers in in certain fields who
actually do
really well you say you do it because
you know just for the pleasure the
enjoyment
will say no that comes as a result of it
um i enjoy it and then you can use it as
a sign
of whether the person has acquired that
that virtue
but they're not doing it just for the
pleasure likewise you know
doing the wrong thing would be painful
for them
but they're not not doing the wrong
thing just to avoid pain
um because then that wouldn't be that
wouldn't be virtuous the vicious person
by the way has
the opposite thing the vicious person
enjoys doing the wrong thing that's why
you know it's so hard for them to stop
doing the wrong thing
they think it's the right thing and they
enjoy it and they also enjoy
other people doing it but let's let's go
on
uh these are these are important uh
questions and distinctions
so um we want to develop an adequate
understanding about what each of these
virtues and vices are so sometimes
that's actually going to mean
developing new vocabulary aristotle
actually says we don't have a name for
this virtue
i'm going to make up a name like for
example right ambition
he says we don't have we have you know
being ambitious and being unambitious
what's the right amount you know how
much drive do you have
what are you willing to do in order to
attain position
attain honor prestige further yourself
all those sorts of things there's
actually a right position in the middle
for that
but he says so rare at least in his
society which was under obsessed
that we don't have a name for it yet so
i'll just call it right ambition
now we we have stuff like that but
perhaps there's dispositions
in our current culture where we don't
yet have the moral vocabulary
and we would want to develop them anger
is not one of them
we've been thinking about that for a
long time
i'm actually going to skip i was going
to have you do a an exercise
but i'm actually going to skip over it
just in order to save on
on time um i i have a handout about um
this one's pretty dense as well
aristotle's
analysis of the nature and the causes
of anger
why are we looking at this we're looking
to try to understand
anger as an emotional response what
happens when we
get angry why why do people get angry
if we can get a good handle on that then
we can have a really good sense
of when it could be good when it could
be bad
so one of the things you're going to
notice he has a very complex definition
of anger
a working definition i don't want to say
this is like the be-all end-all
definition because he gives several
different definitions this one is coming
from a book called the art of rhetoric
which if you're going to go to law
school you'll probably read
if you're going to go into rat comp
you'll probably read as well
because it tells you you know how to
persuade people how to make an
argument how to make a case and he
thinks that it's important to understand
the emotions so that you can
recognize when people are feeling them
when
uh you want to cultivate them how to
steer them and how to
calm you know emotions like anger in
your audience
he also has advice too which is a little
bit uh
not quite so good but how to steer anger
from one person
against you know anger against one
person to another person
your opponent in debate not quite so
nice there but
the rhetoric is designed to be sort of a
handbook for
people who are going to be involved in
making cases
so he says it's a desire
when you're angry there's something
you want it's not just that your blood
is boiling or your face is turning red
you want something what is it that you
want he says
uh for apparent retribution
hemorrhages timorasis means sort of
setting things right
restoring what was damaged fixing things
uh and he's got this word apparent i
translate it as a parent there
it could also be translated as public it
could be translated
as even imaginary this uh you know
fontasia
phenomena phenomena in greek
so that's what it wants it wants a
parent retribution
why well it's produced by what we call
a sliding sliding is when you're you're
you know we often talk about people
being one up and one down are you guys
familiar with this sort of
terminology i you know i i insult you or
i bully you
so that i'm above you in some way
i just you know make a crack nice shirt
you know
i'm trying to actually like you know put
myself up higher
and you lower that's what a sliding is
leaving that one penny as the tip real
sliding
saying your service is terrible or at
least it was today
um so an apparent sliding now notice the
role of the parent there
in order to make somebody mad do you
actually have to do something bad to
them
let's be honest about ourselves in order
for us to get mad
does somebody actually have to do
something that's actually bad to us
or is it possible for us to get mad in
all sorts of other
cases i got mad today because i missed a
turn
stupid you know and i was thinking about
can this fit aristotle's definition
you know who am i mad at the people who
designed the road the people who put the
signs
i just wasn't paying attention and so
you know we're we're 90
and 87 split i wasn't paying attention i
just you know mindlessly drove onto 90
and i did make a little detour
and you know i've actually one reason
why i'm interested in angers i've been a
very angry person
in my life and thankfully i've gotten
better with that
and with this in the past i would have
been furious
those stupid road designers now did they
actually try to screw me by putting the
roads where they were
the signs no and whose fault actually
was it was my fault cause i wasn't
paying attention
but you notice that you can have that
anger response i i know that
intersection
i think it's the road designers they
really are just as bad as
now you're now you're just you know well
but you know what i'm talking about
do you guys think it's a bad design
i mean it's not like they it's not like
some states where the signage is
actually wrong
you know what well new york
when you get into the city some of the
signage is actually incorrect
you know there's also in some of the
towns around us people enjoy turning the
street signs 90 degrees
you know so you don't know what street
you're on thank god for gps
because i'd get lost pretty easily
there they're actually doing something
kind of malicious aren't they you could
get angry about that
but it's not like they said i am gonna
get this guy
you know so the appearance the the the
the um imaginary function of it is
important
um sliding against who against oneself
we get angry when people do wrong to us
we also get angry aristotle says
when people do wrong to those who are
connected with us
who might that be who's connected with
you
who do you get angry when people do
something to that person yeah family and
friends
those are those are the roots would you
guys get angry if somebody did something
to
let's say somebody's got a green
mountain college
shirt on and you guys don't have enough
of a town to have like you know county
versus um
college student conflicts like some
places do but let's say
you had that sort of thing and so you
see somebody getting pushed around
they're wearing a green mountain
sweatshirt they're a freshman you don't
know them they just showed up on campus
would you get mad i probably would and
you know it was something from one of my
schools
um now how are they connected to you
okay they're part of your community yeah
what were you gonna say
that's the key term we identify with
with other people
the fact that we are beings in
relationship
makes our ability to get angry
much wider than that of the other
animals i mean you know
animals will get angry when you do what
to them dogs pull their tail
um you learn really early on your
parents say don't pull the dog's tail
you go and you pull the dog's tail
because you want to find out what will
happen and then you find out you're
going to get bit
and the dog will snarl at you right they
don't like that
any of you ever tried to take a dog's
food away i did it once
and my loving dog she turned on me and
bit up my face that's an anger response
um now a dog might get upset if
you know you're going after its puppies
or if it's formed a strong
bond with a human being or another dog
or even cats that it's looking after
but a dog is not going to see some other
dog over there
you know who's the same breed as it
getting kicked by somebody and say i
need to go over there and mess with them
because i'm mad that doesn't happen
you know insects kind of seem like
they're getting angry but we don't even
know
what's going on in their little brains
you know like you
kill a yellow jacket the other yellow
jackets will come and sting you
turns out that's that's just pheromones
it's not an anger response at all
but we can get angry about all sorts of
stuff because we can identify
with all sorts of people um
do any of you ever get angry on on
social media
yes yes why oh because
people are saying things that either
don't make sense or aren't backed
up correctly or just plain wrong yeah
they you know why does that bother us so
much
i mean people are in general
not not a very bright species and we do
a lot of dumb stuff i mean i
i know i've done a lot of dumb stuff
myself i'm still doing dumb stuff
occasionally
44 i should know better um why does that
bother us so much
i mean we we can all relate to that
right i think getting on social media if
you're like
read down in comment sections facebook
is one thing but comment sections
wow if you want to find some fodder for
fueling your anger
great place to go yeah our response to
people being stupid is like a trigger
response because we don't like ourselves
so seeing it in other people like
triggers that response that we feel for
an interesting theory i don't know that
that that applies that widely
um be interesting to try to
hand that out as an explanation for
things i think in a lot of cases
it's more like that's a stupid thing
they're saying and
i don't it's not reflecting on on you
know me as being stupid
i just think they're wrong and why the
hell did they post it there in the first
place they have no right to do that
and they're probably you know
denigrating somebody who i actually like
and you know just goes on and on from
there you guys are kind of familiar with
how this works right
so these are all components of it he
also talks about pain and pleasure being
involved in anger the pain
is caused by all of this the pleasure is
actually in
taking or imagining retribution
and if we're honest with ourselves i
think that we can see that that that's
part of what goes on
aristotle talks about three main
categories
of what he's calling sliding and does
this cover everything i don't think so
um when he gets to some of the dynamics
he has some other things that that
fit in there as well but these are these
do cover a lot of ground
contempt what he calls cataphronesis in
in greek
is like looking down on somebody else
so if if i come in here and i treat you
like you're
you you guys know nothing i'm just here
to
fill you all with my wonderful knowledge
how many of you
would get irritated only
only half of you the rest of you are
like yeah that's fine
that's exactly what i expect in a
college professor know i'd get irritated
if i was in the audience
i sometimes walk out of people's papers
i don't i don't think they're any good
um not not as much these days thank god
but
what kind of foreign aces um there's a
lot of ways to do this
saying snide things about somebody
doing actions that show that you don't
value them
here's a great example how many of you i
don't know if you guys have this dynamic
here but my students
at other colleges hate doing group
assignments
you guys hate doing group why why don't
you like doing group assignments
yeah one person usually ends up doing
most of the work and the other people do
what
well that's what they do during the work
what do they do afterwards
they take the credit now what does that
say what does that say about those
people and their view about that one
person who's doing the work
what message are they sending
value yeah well they don't value them
they value their contribution so they
can take it and then say
it was great to be in this group
together talk to you next year um
but they don't value the person that's
that's what aristotle's calling
cataphronesis
looking down at somebody um spitefulness
some people just like to screw with
other people he's got this great greek
word for this
you know we would call it malice
when somebody's malicious they just
enjoy
hurting other people causing them
problems but not actually getting
anything out of it
they just you know they just are doing
it to do it and people do that sort of
thing
if we use driving examples what would be
some examples of driving behavior
that might fit into that tailgating
what's that somebody said cutting
somebody
off yeah just just for the sake of
cutting them off merges are a bad thing
for this
speeding up while you're back oh yeah
see and there's there's an example where
you could have like two people getting
furious with each other right yeah
um some of those are spiteful
now then there's what he calls hubris
and you guys are probably familiar with
this term
in a different context we talk about
somebody having hubris
we usually mean they're like you know
thinking that they're the champion
and the hubris goes before a fall the
greeks meant much something much wider
than it could be walking up somebody
smacking them in the face
it could be saying bad things about them
usually had a sort of openness to it and
it was done basically
to enjoy dominating the other person or
enjoy
hurting the other person uh it's like
cataphronesis except cataphronesis is a
little bit more low-key
hubris is pretty pretty severe stuff you
can actually prosecute somebody
in some of the greek courts for for
hubris for the crime of hubris
um so aristotle talks about these
these uh things that's causing anger in
us then it gives us these dynamics of
anger
um one of them one of the ones that's
the most interesting
is that people get angry when another
person prevents or hinders or even fails
to help them with something
that they want so i was thinking as i
was driving up here
if my wife had been in the car when i
made the mistake and i was going the
wrong way
and let's say she hadn't seen either
that could have led to
you know one of these tense situations
where i'm trying to figure out how
how am i going to get back onto the
highway that i need to be on and she's
trying to give me advice
and i feel like it's not actually
helping me and now i start to get angry
stupidly but that's something that
happens with us quite
often um people think that they're being
helpful for us
and it turns out that they're actually
hindering us we get angry
we often feel people find people getting
angry at us when we try to help them
we have that happen as well so that's
one important dynamic
another really interesting dynamic
aristotle
points out he's a great psychologist
people get
really angry when
you make fun of something that they care
about
it doesn't have to be a person or the
philosopher he uses as an
example it could be philosophy
philosophy is stupid i don't know why
anyone studies that sort of
you know nonsense philosophers often
will get angry about that sort of thing
or you know when did you ever have them
like
your family confused philosophy and
psychology for a long time
you're studying psychology
yeah that can you know if people seem
like they don't they don't know what
you're
interested in um they belittle it
now here's where it gets really
interesting aristotle says people do get
upset about that sort of stuff but who
gets the most upset about that who would
you
would guess like let's say we're going
to talk about pick something out of the
air
um anybody hear a gear head
you're into cars or trucks you work on
them
oh yeah so what's your what's like your
favorite model
oh yeah bmw's stupid i don't know why
you want to drive that
that german stuff should be
american-made
you've probably heard things like this
right at one time motorcycle people are
terrible about that
you know it's the japanese versus the
americans versus the german
manufacturers um now if you
actually feel secure about your you know
capacities
as a mechanic about your knowledge of it
you don't care if people
smack like that right because they don't
know what they're talking about
but if you feel insecure and somebody's
making fun of something that you
identify with
that can really trigger an anger
response aristotle
writes about this at that length because
he's observing this
in other people so who gets upset when
you make fun of philosophy
people who aren't very good at it who
gets upset when you talk about you know
make fun of cooking it's not the chefs
it's the people who want to be chefs
who get upset about that this is a very
useful
model for anger for understanding what
goes on
when we get angry i also gave you
another
worksheet and you notice it's got all
these elements
in it i took aristotle's thing and you
can see about
how many do all of you get angry any of
you never get angry
totally calm you never get angry that
would be a blissful life
that would be wonderful so you probably
can't fill this out though
but but the rest of you you can imagine
somebody else
somebody else getting angry the rest of
you can fill that out
and think about you know ways and
expressions of getting angry
let's think now about actual virtues and
vices
so we know we do get angry
we know that aristotle says that virtues
are in the middle position
vices are on the extremes
which extreme do you think most people
tend to
too much too little
in our society you think it's too much
you think it's too little yeah
that's too little okay so
what would be some examples of people
that get
angry too little yeah
you're going to say too much okay we'll
come back i mean aristotle and his
society he's like yeah
too much is clearly the winner here but
maybe
maybe in our contemporary society we
have people
who don't get angry enough yeah
yeah now that's a really interesting one
that aristotle
does talk about a bit he actually
locates that
on the side of too much in a way
the people who just hold on to their
anger he calls them the bitter and we'll
come to them in a moment yeah
i would kind of agree with that because
yeah and sometimes people get passive
aggressive those are people that kind of
correspond to what aristotle calls the
jalapos that i could you know literally
translated it
no it's not literally it's figuratively
it's pains in the asses
the kind of people that are troublesome
usually troublesome is how
how we translate that yeah
oh yeah now there's other virtues and
other vices that can be
connected with that but um
how would that fit in with anger
they don't get angry when they should
people are are
imposing on them people are and they
sort of take it
yeah so aristotle does talk about about
that he um
i gave you the last handout of all these
handouts that i'm getting it's vices and
virtue is concerned with anger i put it
into a schema
i've actually done this with all of
aristotle's virtues and vices
um there's there's a website i can i can
send you to
if you want that sort of stuff if you're
into that kind of thing
um he talks about people as being
inaraskable
that means they they don't get angry
when they should
and he also uses the term slavish andro
uh
andro andra pododes
greek word for that um and he thinks
that the people who are stuck in a
one-down position
often can't get angry they can't express
their anger
here's a little you know this is not to
his credit doesn't really care about
those people that much he's more
concerned
with with you know certain strata of
society we don't have to
go that route we could say well there
are some people who don't get to express
their anger that's a bad thing for them
uh because then they're stuck in this
this other position
where it starts to become second nature
to suck it up
swallow it to say well uh like you were
talking about
people who don't say no say i guess i
had it coming to me i guess i'm that
kind of person it's okay to insult me
and
treat me badly and you know their
self-esteem goes further and further
down
um aristotle says that it's it's a
problem when people don't get angry when
they ought to get angry
and they accept insults and humiliating
treatment
so here aristotle would be at odds with
um
quite a lot of other thinkers about
anger you know
um because some people actually say well
you know should be humble and let people
do whatever
whatever they want to um aristotle would
say well
that's completely crazy that's a vice
that becomes a bad habit that becomes
part of who you are and then when you
realize it and you want to escape it
you you have a very hard time getting
away from it did you have another
question or are you just stretching
that's okay i usually i used to do that
all the time when i was in class
stretch my arms like that i must have
confused my my professors an awful lot
um what's that
some of my my professors would get
really angry i mean
things were quite different in our
generation of
of uh college and and k through 12
teachers i remember this is a total
digression
but it just brings to mind when i was in
sixth grade we had
we had a drama class and you know it was
middle school and so there were these
kids coming from all over the place
and everybody had to do like a skit
you know practice your drama and these
these kids that had all gone to the same
school
they acted out this skit where and this
was like an actual case
a teacher had slammed a student's head
into a chalkboard
and severely hurt the student and she
went to she went to jail
she was taken out of the classroom and
you know rightly so
um and you know we were all like
what was that about but it wasn't you
know unimaginable for us because things
like that
you know those sort of things happen
quite a bit
um i think there's a lot better
control over that sort of thing now
don't you
i hope i mean not in some areas i
suppose
um but i still remember all the meetings
did you get beaten
we got paddled yeah in school you know
yeah we um yes
yeah punishment was regarded spare the
rod
we had that in middle school but it
wasn't with a paddle thank god
and then it wasn't like that in high
school but yeah i mean
aristotle actually has another funny
story he talks about this is a person
who doesn't have proper proportion when
it comes to anger
he talks about a guy who um drags his
dad
by the scruff of his neck because he's
having a fight with his dad
out to the doorstep and then drops him
there and
um when people blame him for that
he says well that's how far he
he dragged his father when he got mad at
his father so i'm doing
just what's allowed me you know i'm
following an example
i'm expressing my anger in the right way
because look i mean he
he thought it was okay to do that so
obviously it's okay to do it to him
and everyone else around him is like
you're you're not getting the point here
you know um but there there are things
like that
let's look at the vicious dispositions
the excesses
there's little names a bunch of these
you know why
a lot of different ways we go wrong with
anger and they're they're not all the
same
um maybe some of you will identify you
know people that you know or even
yourself in these
the quick temper they get angrier they
get angry quicker than they want to
with the wrong people over the wrong
things the good thing about these people
we call them hot heads
they quit being angry pretty quickly
so you probably have some friends like
that right
or family members they're easy to anger
they they don't pay attention aristotle
says that anger is like a hasty servant
who hears half of the orders and then
rushes off to go do the work
anger is like that in that it hears
something and it says i'm being insulted
somebody's
you know sliding me and it may not
actually be the case and it goes
off to the emotion
um now you know people like that can be
a problem
but you can sort of reign them in if you
have the right you know institutional
things
much more worrisome the rageful
uh acro holloway the akron high
they get angry quickly and they get
angry over everything these are the
people who need anger management classes
because it's gone so far that they get
angry over everything
anything can set them all you know any
people like that
yeah um there's some cartoon characters
like that too
now here it gets really interesting the
bitter temper the picoi
that literally means bitter that's the
taste uh that
you know in greek you know that we
associate with bitterness
like when you uh
want to be a bitter thing to eat like
almonds beer is bitter
now imagine that intensified and now
imagine that turned into an emotion
these are the people who get angry for a
long time why
they keep their anger in this is what we
were talking about before
and they just nurse their anger they're
not satisfied until they actually get to
exact their revenge their retaliation
even if it's imaginary until they get
their as we say pound of flesh
they're not going to be satisfied they
may not appear angry which is why
they're dangerous
but they will you know be motivated by
that emotion
then we have the troublesome they become
troublesome
more than they should and for a longer
time and they won't be reconciled
without some sort of retribution
or punishment um of the other person not
punishment of themselves but
punishment of the other person and these
are the kind of people that are just a
pain in the rear
you know you know you know people who
are kind of sour
and they always seem to need to have
something to be upset about
you know any people like that because if
that's part of their character that's
that's become advice
and they're not when when you point that
out to those people what do they respond
aristotle doesn't talk about that but we
could go further what do they usually
say have any of you ever pointed that
out to a person you're kind of a
kind of a sour puss kind of you know
kind of grumpy all the time what's wrong
with you
why are you like that nice day
but you know these people that you keep
complaining about i don't see anything
wrong with them
yeah i think those of you that feel like
they can like never catch a break or
they feel the world's out to get them
yeah so that's part of it
um you know when we think about why
people become
angry there is that sense that like the
whole world is slighting me
all all of them you get without that
expression all y'all
you know all you all are are doing that
and then the north would be all used
guys in the cities
yeah um so it seems like murky waters to
me because on one
end of the spectrum you have the hot
head yeah who gets mad at everything but
his anger is quick to fade
and on the other hand you have the
bitter person who nurses nurses their
anger and
it changes who they are yeah so where is
aristotle drawing this middle way like
oh we're getting to that okay
these are all on the side of excess but
they're different ways of being
excessive
you know this is one of those places
where um
aristotle's schema there's always like
one virtue
one virtue one vice one vice there's
actually a bunch of licensed
things they look differently from each
other
let's jump to that there's there's also
the violent or abusive that he talks
about
these are people who are just like you
know got to watch out for them because
they're always engaging in retaliation
these are the people who get in bar
fights and kick people you know their
ribs when they're down
but those are the people you have to
really watch out for um
the virtuous disposition in greek it's
called praguetes
the good person in that respect is
called pravis and when you are reading
other literature you may see it
described as meek
for example when you're reading biblical
literature
moses is described as prous
the same word is also used in you know
the beatitudes blessed are the meek
it's blessed are the prouds um
now you know moses is kind of a tough
guy so
he's not it's not like he never lost his
temper
um but the the question is
what is this this meekness it's better
to translate into something like
you know getting angry at the right time
for the right reasons with the right
people to the right degree it's not a
matter of not getting angry at all
for aristotle this kind of meekness or
gentleness or good temperedness
he says this person gets angry at the
right time to the right degree with the
right people there's all these rights in
place
now is that is there a subjective
element to that yes
it's uh will it be in to some degree
contingent on the societies that we're
in
probably but that doesn't mean that we
can't have some sort of outlines for
what
is productive anger um and what is
you know uh self-destructive or
destructive of other
people and our relationships with them
sort of anger and it could vary from
place to place so for example in my
family
i come from a a french canadian family
and
when i was a kid we yelled at each other
a lot we didn't you know
you only got hit if you were being
punished and that was adults
and kids primarily but adults would
routinely yell at each other
and i've been in in um other people's
households
where yelling was a sign that everything
was going to fall apart
i have a friend who's a
from a household like that he would
never imagine
his parents or his brothers and sisters
yelling at each other
it actually did happen and when it did
happen it was pretty much like a family
emergency
now those are expressions of anger
and there's a subjectivity to that right
you know
is can you draw hard and fast rules
about how much can you yell
that's not what aristotle's talking
about he's talking about it being ruled
by some sort of you know flexible
standard you might say
right reason and that's going to be hard
to adapt
any of you ever read the book emotional
intelligence
it starts out with a quote from
aristotle about anger
how anger is difficult to say it's
difficult to say who you should be angry
with how long for
because these things you know there's
some play in them
but you can say you know you could you
could say to somebody
are you angry with this person for the
right reason
that's something that you could ask
somebody something they could ask you
something you could ask yourself if the
answer is no
you're probably skewing towards one side
or the other right
are you angry when you should be there's
another
question you could ask yourself are you
actually angry at the right person
if i if i get upset because of the
signage
and let's say the designers were really
at fault how many of you from the region
think they were at fault
anybody very few okay
so what's that
what was the question uh there's there's
like a
highway split this is just sort of a
local thing um
is the signage good enough so that
somebody like me should be able to
actually figure out whether to go on 87
or 90
or do i get to blame them get angry at
them for putting the signs
you know they should have marked it more
clearly or something like that
that's a really stupid thing to get
angry about but if my wife is in the car
and i turn my snap at her
that's not virtuous anger right i'm
angry with the wrong person in that case
this happens just quite often
um he also talks about people like this
as being disposed to forgive
so the person who's got a good
disposition with respect to anger
probably not going to get very angry
very often
when they get angry it's going to be
fairly reasonable
it's not going to be something you know
rage that you know crests over
and destroys everything it's going to be
fairly
restrained but they are going to feel
angry but they're also going to be the
kind of person who is willing to say
oh you know you bumped into me not going
to get angry over that or i did get
angry a little bit but offer i'll just
you know i'll write it off i'll accept
your apology
it won't be a big thing they may even be
tempted to forgive
other things aristotle doesn't think
that forgiveness should be unconditional
he thinks that if somebody does
something and they're doing it because
they're a bad person you don't forgive
that
so he's a little bit different than some
theorists when it comes to forgiveness
but he's willing to say that it's it's
pretty important
so does this give you yeah go ahead
i understand the whole concept of
positive anger and how it can be
positively pursued but can someone argue
that there are other ways
of resolving the problem
well yeah you're saying that there could
be a situation in which
being angry and then acting on anger
might not lead to the best outcomes yeah
aristotle would have no problem with
that but we are going to get angry
and he he does think that anger does
play an important role
in you know sort of
making sure that people actually know
that they're doing the wrong thing
he's not saying that you know you want
to be angry all the time
but there is a legitimate scope for it
where i wanted to go
in particular with this is thinking
about
can anger be something that's useful
something that's needed
in say protesting injustice did you ever
hand up
well for not forgiving and resentment
aren't the same thing to begin with
um i mean you just you can just think to
yourself that person's a complete you
know
bastard and i'm just going to dislike
them
well yeah i mean not all
not not all instances of not forgiving
lead to resentment resentment is when
you actually like nurse some sort of
grudge against a person
i just like you know i could have
somebody who does something
wrong to me and they did it because
they're they're a bad person i get angry
at them i act on it i don't forgive them
and then after i've you know done
something in response to them hey
jackass knock it off i'm no longer angry
because i've had my timoresis in that
case and i'm no longer resentful um
or i could you know um go around and say
that person's a bad person
that's not yet resentment resentment is
you know something a bit more
a bit more seated
it's important to have like a bunch of
gradations of these these emotions
because our emotional life is
complicated let's go back to that
question though
is there is there a possibility given
this sort of account of anger
for using anger say for doing activism
or for calling people's attention
to things that are wrong yeah i would
say
no because um it is quantum it can be
controlled if it's only
one person doing it but if you have a
group of people being angry at one
single yeah yeah it's they're not only
being angry at it but they're also being
argued differently which causes
a lot of different complexity where it's
really hard to
control yeah that's true you can't you
can't predict like
everyone's going to be virtuous yeah i i
definitely say where you're coming from
but i think it can also be a time where
everyone's angry and like united by that
anger and it doesn't have to be a bad
anger because you can have good anger
towards a positive situation so you can
channel that anger
and like make a change
you can think of it as emotional raw
material which then flows into
these habits so you know i i'm very
attuned to what what you're thinking of
with
let's say i there's a cause that i
really believe in somebody's doing
something
wrong with somebody i want to call
people's attention to it i frame my
argument in such a way as to arouse
anger
because i'm you know good at rhetoric or
something like that
that emotion can be very useful as a raw
material to get things done
there may be some people who are in my
audience
who are vicious with respect to anger
like the person who gets angry over
everything
and now i'm i'm not directly responsible
but i bear some responsibility for the
anger that they feel which then they
take out on all their co-workers
because they read my internet article
something like that
yeah i understand that you can be
responsible but
to some to some extent yeah
okay i'm not wholly responsible they
can't they can't like say
it's all doctor sadler's fault if i
hadn't read that article
because they because they're the one
who's vicious right they have the
disposition
you know the last thing i guess i would
say too is aristotle thinks we have
control
not directly but control over our
virtues and vices
we decide the kind of people that we're
going to be and so we bear some
responsibility if i have anger problems
um you know it could because my dad was
an angry person and everybody around me
yelled a lot
you know we had you know all sorts of
crazy stuff going on with our kids but
at a certain point i actually have to
stop up and say
yeah i i need to like decide whether i
want to be
on this end of the spectrum or over here
or in the middle because i'm the one who
has to decide yeah
oh
yeah i wasn't thinking genetically i'm
actually adopted um
well right that's what i was saying i'm
saying we are
aristotle saying we are responsible by
the time that we're adults for our
virtues and vices
and if we want to quit being vicious we
actually have to do quite a bit of work
to wean ourselves away from it if we
happen to wind up virtuous
good for us that's pretty rare most of
the time we have to work at it
in order to make it happen so
thanks for your time and attention